-So, after the draft decision --
the draft decision
overturning Roe v. Wade
was leaked last month,
we wrote a sketch
and we filmed it last week,
because unlike, I don't know,
the Democratic leadership,
we saw this coming.
[ Laughter ]
So...here's our sketch
that we filmed last week
from "Late Night" writer
Jeff Wright.
-As you all know,
there's been a leaked draft,
and one of us is on it.
-A draft? Are we going to war?
-No, a drafted proposal
to overturn one of us.
-Damn, that's sad.
Well, sorry to see you go,
Loving v. Virginia.
Interracial marriage
had its run.
-What? Interracial marriage?
I'm all about how love
doesn't see color.
-Yeah, but we don't need a law
to prove that anymore.
The Kardashians
already solidified that.
-Well, then get rid of
Obergefell v. Hodges
and gay marriage.
-What? Gay marriage? No way.
I'm all about love, too.
Plus I'm the newest,
and I was passed
while Obama was in office.
They wouldn't want to
get rid of something Obama did.
-If you ask me,
I think it's Roe v. Wade.
-What makes you say that?
-Well, because it says here,
"Draft to overturn Roe v. Wade."
-What?
-Damn.
-I knew it was him.
-Wait, you made us guess
when you had it on your phone
this whole time?
-Hey, man. Let's focus
on Roe v. Wade
and them possibly
overturning abortions.
-To think they're okay with
overturning a woman's
constitutional right is just...
-Just wrong.
-Terrible.
-[Bleep] up.
Hey, but, Roe,
we gonna hold it down in here.
-What do you mean hold it down?
The way I see it
is if I get overturned,
we're all getting overturned.
-Overturned with you?
I didn't get that notification
on my phone.
-Don't need to.
The way I see it is if I'm gone,
nobody's safe.
Yes, abortions now, but next
it'll be gay marriage.
-Oh, don't say that.
-Then it'll be
interracial marriage.
-Man, I just want to love
white people. Is that wrong?
-Whoa.
-What? Love is love.
-Yeah, love is love, but chill.
-Next they'll take away
my constitutional right
to have guns.
-You know damn well they're
not doing anything about guns.
-You right.
Well, I guess I'll just
get back to ordering more guns.
Oh, shoot. There's a
two-for-one. Anybody want one?
-But they'll overturn
everything else.
Next thing you know, they'll
segregate our schools again.
-Come on, now. Not the kids.
Times have changed.
-Have they, though?
I mean, people are still getting
chastised for how they look,
who they love, or what they
want to do with their bodies.
-You got a point.
What should we do?
-Ooh.
What if when they come
for Roe v. Wade
we turn off all the lights
and pretend we aren't here?
-Man, how would that even work?
-They would just
turn the lights back on.
-I was just trying to help.
-The best we can do
is stick tog--
-Shh! You heard that?
I think someone's going.
-I'm not going out
without a fight.
-I'll get the lights.
♪♪
[ Door creaks ]
-Huh. I guess Roe v. Wade
isn't here.
♪♪
-Huh? Huh?
See? I told you turning
off the lights would work.
-He's -- He's right behind you.
He's right behind --
-He's right behind me, isn't he?
Aw, [bleep].
-Y'all sure
y'all don't want a gun?